En juillet 1789,
la Révolution française secoue une
première fois les pouvoirs monarchiques.
Louis XVI est alors obligé de composer
avec une Assemblée nationale.
En deux ans,
le roi est peu à peu dépouillé
de tous ses pouvoirs
et assigné à résidence
au palais des Tuileries.
Pourtant, à mesure que Louis XVI se rallie
à l'idée d'une monarchie constitutionnelle
sa liberté s'amenuise de jour en jour.
Jusqu'à ce 21 juin
où le roi décide de fuir avec sa famille,
ceux qui le manipulent.
Cette évasion
signera l'arrêt de mort de la monarchie,
ouvrant à la Révolution française,
la voie d'un régime
jusqu'alors impensable,
la République.
Voilà,
heure par heure,
comment s'est déroulée
cette incroyable évasion
qui a changé le cours
de l'histoire de France.
Père, je ne veux pas m'habiller
comme une fille.
Vous les surprendrez tous,
travesti comme cela.
Je préfère mon costume
de capitaine des gardes.
Peut-être
pourrions-nous l'emporter
et vous changer
une fois la fête commencée.
Laissez, mère,
vous vous êtes fait mal ?
- N'oubliez pas vos rôles,
nous ne devons pas être reconnus,
c'est la règle
des fêtes costumées.
Si on vous demande votre identité ?
Je suis Amélie Rochet
et voici ma petite sœur Aglaé.
Je ne m'appelle pas Aglaé.
Madame de Tourzel,
emmenez les enfants au carrosse.
- Venez, les enfants.
N'oubliez pas votre rôle, également.
Fuir cette prison, enfin !
Pourtant,
j'ai tellement peur.
Si l'on nous démasque,
que feront-ils de toi ?
Je n'ose y penser.
Tout va bien se passer Madame.
Tout est au point.
Que Dieu vous entende.
Monsieur de La Fayette.
Votre présence quotidienne
aux Tuileries m'honore,
mais à force,
on pourrait se demander
qui commande véritablement
la Garde nationale.
Sire, le citoyen Bailly
et moi-même,
ne sommes que vos serviteurs.
Je n'en doute pas un instant.
Vous, monsieur Le Maire,
que me racontez-vous ce soir ?
Sire, nous préparons
la procession de la Fête-Dieu
qui doit avoir lieu
le jeudi 23 de ce mois.
C'est très bien, ça, Bailly.
Nous avons pour projet
de passer l'été à Saint-Cloud,
j'espère que ces messieurs
de l'Assemblée n'y verront rien à redire.
Je ne crois pas
que cela soit possible.
- Je suis un roi sans pouvoirs
au milieu d'une cour fantôme.
L'Assemblée nationale a pris ma place.
On nous a privé de nos libertés,
une par une.
On me refuse tout,
même de pratiquer la religion
dans laquelle je suis né.
Enfermé aux Tuileries
avec ce maudit de La Fayette pour geôlier.
Je n'ai pas d'autre choix,
nous partirons ce soir.
Sire ?
Quand je pense que j'ai fait
la renommée de ce petit marquis
en l'envoyant
combattre en Amérique.
Patience,
mon cher La Fayette,
vous allez bientôt avoir
une fort mauvaise surprise.
Nous allons vous souhaiter
une bonne nuit, Sire.
Comme c'est généreux à vous,
mes amis.
Passez,
messieurs.
En 1791,
Louis XVI a 36 ans.
Il n'est pas le personnage
lourd et débonnaire
dont on a fait la légende noire,
mais un homme intelligent et cultivé.
Si la décision
de partir est risquée,
du moins,
le roi l'a-t-il mûrement réfléchie.
- Je suis roi et pourtant,
je ne suis rien.
Seigneur, vous m'avez choisi
pour veiller sur le peuple de France,
mais pour sauver la vie de ma famille,
je suis contraint
de m'évader comme un hors-la-loi.
Aidez-moi,
Seigneur, à surmonter mes craintes.
Sire, je suis monsieur Durand,
intendant de la baronne de Korff,
pour vous servir.
Sire.
- Sire ?
Il n'y a plus de roi, Malden,
mais ce bon monsieur Durand.
Allons,
pressons-nous.
Ne paniquez pas,
mon brave Malden,
rien ne nous arrivera
si vous ne faites rien d'irréfléchi.
- C'est que j'ai peur, Sire.
J'ai peur qu'un des gardes
ne vous reconnaisse.
Bonsoir, citoyen Coigny.
- Bonsoir.
Citoyen Coigny ?
Depuis deux semaines,
j'ai pris la précaution
de faire sortir par cette même porte
le chevalier de Coigny,
dont la tournure est semblable
à la mienne aujourd'hui.
Allons Malden,
du courage, mon ami.
Les enfants sont là Fersen ?
Oui, Sire, ainsi que madame Élisabeth,
depuis plus d'une heure.
Tout s'est bien passé
aux Tuileries,
personne n'a rien remarqué
de notre absence, allons-y.
C'est que nous attendons
toujours la reine, Sire.
Je n'aurais pas dû vous confier
l'organisation de l'évasion de ma femme.
Je suis certain
que la reine ne va pas tarder.
J'espère que vos plans
sont aussi bien dessinés
que les traits de votre visage Fersen.
- Ayez confiance.
Sachez, monsieur,
que je ne prodigue ma confiance
qu'à très peu de gens.
Si la reine n'avait pas tant insisté,
j'aurais confié
cette entreprise à un autre.
Je vais la chercher.
- Je vous accompagne.
- Laissez-moi.
Toute cette violence,
toute cette haine,
le peuple de Paris
a déjà voulu tuer la reine,
c'était un jour d'octobre
à Versailles,
quand des hordes d'hommes déguisés
en femme ont forcé les portes du palais.
Sire, des femmes sont
à Versailles.
Que veulent-elles ces femmes ?
- Elles réclament du pain, Sire.
Hélas, si j'en avais,
je le leur donnerais.
Elles veulent aussi que la famille royale
quitte Versailles pour habiter Paris.
Quitter le château de mes pères ?
Jamais.
Elles sont armées, Sire.
- Des femmes armées ?
En-avant, messieurs.
- Allez, allez, allez !
Alors que la capitale
est au bord de la famine,
les Parisiennes se mettent en marche
avec l'intention
de ramener le roi à Paris.
Le 6 octobre 1789,
le palais de Versailles
est en état de siège.
Les femmes réclament des pains
et la peau de la reine.
- À mort l'Autrichienne !
À mort l'Autrichienne !
On nous a dit
de les ramener à Paris, au pire.
- À bas l'Autrichienne !
Venez mes amours, je suis là.
Elle va
nous le payer cher.
Allez !
Je vais lui ouvrir le ventre
avec mon couteau.
Ne vous inquiétez pas.
Tous avec moi, allez !
À la garde.
Empruntez le passage.
- Père ?
On veut parler au roi.
À mort l'Autrichienne !
À mort !
Ce n'est rien,
cette folie est passagère.
- Pour calmer les esprits
et protéger sa famille,
Louis XVI obtempère,
il accepte de quitter son palais.
Prisonnière de la Révolution,
la famille royale roule vers Paris
et le château des Tuileries.
Jamais ils ne reverront Versailles.
On avait dit à droite
ou à gauche ?
Je ne sais plus, Madame.
Tu as l'air perdu,
ma mignonne.
Tu veux qu'on t'aide ?
- Ah ! Ah !
Tout va bien,
calmez-vous.
Vous pouvez rentrer,
madame, merci.
Vous vous êtes encore perdue ?
Mon carrosse n'est pas loin.
La Fayette quitte les Tuileries.
Partons maintenant.
Tout va bien, mon ange.
Mon frère, puis-je ?
Je vous en prie,
madame, faites donc.
Où allons-nous
après Montmédy ?
Nous avons convenu
de passer par la Lorraine.
Nous ne resterons pas
dans ce trou à Montmédy ?
Madame, un roi qui fuit
et franchit la frontière de son pays,
est un roi qui trahit.
Vous voulez dire
que nous ne quittons pas la France ?
Faites-moi confiance, ma reine.
Là où nous allons,
une armée nous attend.
J'ai envoyé mon nécessaire
de toilette à Bruxelles, chez ma sœur,
l'archiduchesse Marie-Christine.
Je crois que vous devriez
en faire votre deuil.
Jamais Marie-Antoinette ne comprendra
qu'un roi ne fait pas
la guerre à son peuple.
Je ne peux pas
lui révéler mes intentions.
Dans la nuit du 20
au 21 juin 1791,
Louis XVI,
accompagné de ses proches,
quitte Paris
selon un plan minutieusement préparé.
Pour échapper à la surveillance tatillonne
du général La Fayette,
les fugitifs s'étaient organisés
dans le plus grand secret,
mais comme dans toutes
les histoires romanesques,
s'il y a toujours des héros,
il y a aussi des traîtres.
Merci, messieurs,
ce sera tout pour aujourd'hui.
Je vous en prie,
Léonard, asseyez-vous.
Monsieur de La Fayette,
vous connaissez mon nom ?
Mon bon, tout le monde
connaît le coiffeur de la reine,
vous êtes une sommité,
mon brave.
Vous qui avez réussi
le tour de force d'inventer
et de faire porter une coiffure si haute
que les pauvres femmes qui l'arboraient
devaient se mettre à genoux
pour voyager dans leur carrosse.
Dites-moi, Léonard,
vous voyagez toujours
en compagnie de la reine ?
Sa majesté la reine,
ne laisserait à personne d'autre
le soin de coiffer son illustre personne.
C'est très joliment fait cela,
une composition de votre inspiration ?
Oui, j'utilise des poudres naturelles
avec des pigments
venant exclusivement de Louisiane.
Ah l'Amérique !
J'aimerais que vous m'informiez
du prochain déplacement de la reine.
Pourquoi ferais-je
une telle monstruosité ?
Pour garder vos pigments naturels
de Louisiane sur votre tête, mon cher.
C'est une menace ?
- Oui, de mort.
Un départ précipité
de la famille royale
ne peut s'envisager
que si nous le contrôlons.
Le pays est au bord
de la guerre civile,
mon doux Léonard.
La France a besoin de vous,
monsieur le coiffeur.
Bien monsieur le marquis.
Vous prendrez bien un verre,
mon ami ?
Confier la surveillance
de la famille royale à un coiffeur,
ce La Fayette est
une vraie calamité.
La Fayette sert nos intérêts, Danton.
Pour votre fidélité.
Je m'occuperai de ce La Fayette
quand la République gagnera.
Oui, vous avez raison,
mais en attendant la République,
la régence aura besoin
d'hommes comme vous.
Bien entendu.
Le duc d'Orléans est le cousin du roi,
mais c'est aussi l'un
de ses pires ennemis.
Son ambition est de devenir
régent, puis roi,
afin de remplacer
les Bourbons par les Orléans.
De son point de vue,
le projet d'évasion
du roi est une aubaine,
car son échec
pourrait bien servir ses intérêts.
Monsieur le marquis.
Comment se porte notre affaire ?
- On ne peut mieux, monsieur le duc.
Léonard est en place.
La famille royale ne bougera pas
sans que je ne le sache.
C'est rassurant,
monsieur le marquis,
de savoir que vous contrôlez
ce projet de fuite royale.
Sachez cependant que Danton,
qui ne vous aime pas,
a clamé au Club des Cordeliers
que vous répondiez de votre tête
de la maîtrise de l'opération.
Ne vous inquiétez pas.
Le roi et la reine penseront
échapper à ma surveillance,
mais ils seront sous notre contrôle.
Si vos prédictions s'avèrent exactes,
vous avez devant vous le futur régent.
J'espère
que vous dites vrai
et que vous convaincrez
les Cordeliers du bien-fondé d'une régence
en lieu d'une république.
Tout s'achète,
monsieur de La Fayette, tout.
Même les convictions
les plus ancrées.
Le projet d'évasion prévoyait
que la famille royale voyagerait divisée
et munie de faux passeports.
Madame de Tourzel serait
la baronne de Korff
en route pour la Russie.
Elle serait accompagnée
de la gouvernante et de ses enfants,
madame Rochet,
la reine, et de son intendant,
monsieur Durand, le roi.
Une fois sorti de Paris,
cet équipage laisserait la petite citadine
pour monter
dans une berline de voyage confortable,
digne du rang
de ses illustres passagers.
Une berline de cette taille
avec ces chevaux,
on ne passera pas inaperçu.
Faites selon la volonté du roi, Malden.
Allez !
Allez,
allez, allez !
Apportez les chevaux de rechange, vite.
- Tout de suite, monsieur.
Ne perdez pas de temps, Valory,
filez à Claix
et préparez l'autre relais.
Bien, monsieur.
Sire, il serait peut-être bon
que je vous accompagne ?
Non, je ne crois pas,
monsieur de Fersen.
Nous n'oublierons pas
ce que vous avez fait pour nous.
Je vous ai confié
les sceaux du Royaume
et la mission de nous attendre à Montmédy.
Je vous saurais gré de suivre
les instructions initiales.
Un homme de plus pourrait
s'avérer bien utile, monsieur.
Monsieur de Fersen est bien trop connu
et reconnaissable.
Vous nous feriez prendre
des risques inutiles.
Allez, maintenant.
- Bien, Sire.
Bon voyage,
madame de Korff.
Allez !
« Je ne puis être à la seule personne
à qui je voudrais être. »
« La seule qui m'aime véritablement,
aussi, je ne veux être à personne. »
Voilà ce qu'Axel de Fersen écrit à sa sœur
en parlant de sa bien-aimée, ma femme.
En lisant cette lettre,
mon cœur s'est arrêté.
Louisiane, Philippine.
C'est bien, c'est bien.
Sire, on m'a remis
ces lettres pour vous.
Qui on ?
- Il ne m'a pas donné son nom, Sire.
« Je ne puis être à la seule personne
à qui je voudrais être. »
« La seule qui m'aime véritablement,
aussi, je ne veux être à personne. »
Axel de Fersen.
Sire !
Aidez-moi ! Aidez-moi !
Tout va bien.
Passons à la curée.
Vous êtes en veine ce soir,
ma chère.
C'est à se demander
comment la chose est possible.
Insinuez-vous que la reine triche,
Vaudreuil ?
Je crois, madame,
que vous êtes en train de les ruiner.
Allez !
Les souvenirs se brouillent
dans ma tête.
Est-ce la réalité
ou un cauchemar ?
Madame, madame ?
Parlez,
mon cher baron de Besenval.
On croirait
que vous venez de voir le diable.
C'est le roi,
madame, il arrive.
Dehors tout le monde.
Vous distribuerez
cela aux pauvres.
Eux saurons
en faire bon usage.
La chasse ne vous a pas apporté
de contentement,
heureusement,
il vous reste les serrures.
Ne faites pas l'impudente,
madame.
L'heure est grave.
Monsieur de Fersen est le seul ami sincère
sur qui nous puissions compter.
Ces lettres contiennent
des accusations abominables.
Je vous jure que rien ne s'est rien passé
entre monsieur de Fersen et moi.
Cet homme, ce Fersen,
vous aime.
Qu'y puis-je ?
- Non !
Je n'ai rien à me reprocher.
Je vous promets
de ne plus voir monsieur de Fersen.
Je ne pourrais supporter
de vous perdre,
de vous savoir avec un autre.
Je ne serais jamais
à un autre que vous.
Vous n'êtes pas à moi non plus, Madame.
Cela fait si longtemps
que nos lits ne nous servent qu'à dormir.
Faites éloigner
monsieur de Fersen.
Vous en avez le pouvoir.
Ce serait accorder
du crédit à des rumeurs.
Je préfère
avoir confiance en ma femme.
Je ne vous décevrai pas.
La vérité, je ne sais pas
si Fersen a eu les faveurs de la reine,
probablement pas.
Ma femme est fidèle et croyante,
mais qu'il l'aime
et qu'elle l'ait désiré en retour,
cela m'a toujours déchiré le cœur.
Si seulement elle pouvait me regarder
comme elle regarde Fersen.
Où sommes-nous, Louis ?
Nous sortons
de la forêt de Bondy.
Allez-vous enfin me dire
où vous nous emmenez ?
Nous n'allons pas rejoindre
l'armée de mon frère en terre d'Autriche ?
Permettez-moi de tenir encore
notre destination secrète.
Pourquoi cela ?
Avez-vous donc
si peu confiance en votre femme ?
Toujours votre goût du secret.
Je veux vous protéger
contre vous-même.
Ma chère et pauvre reine,
vous le détestez tellement
ce peuple de France,
que vous seriez prête à le jeter en pâture
à toutes les noblesses d'Europe.
Sire, il est 7 h.
C'est incompréhensible.
Il ne devait pas partir
sans que je ne le sache.
C'est incompréhensible !
Où est Léonard ?
Où est votre coiffeur ?
Romeuf, allez avec Bayon
me chercher cette vermine, maintenant !
Tout de suite, monsieur.
Vous avez fait preuve de légèreté,
monsieur le marquis.
Monsieur le Dauphin,
si c'est un baiser de votre père
que vous réclamez ainsi,
je suis tout disposé à vous l'offrir.
Sommes-nous bientôt
arrivés à la fête, père ?
Pas encore, mon ange.
La disparition de la famille royale
a plongé Paris
dans la confusion la plus totale.
Léonard est introuvable,
le roi s'est volatilisé
et personne n'a la moindre idée
de la route
qu'il a pu emprunter.
Allons-nous dégourdir les jambes,
les enfants.
Louis, arrêtons-nous
pour déjeuner.
De plus, nous sommes déjà éreintés.
S'il vous plaît,
père, nous avons faim.
Louis,
mon frère,
je suis certaine
que vous devez avoir faim comme nous.
Nous pourrions déjeuner
sur l'herbe.
Notre avance est confortable,
vous avez raison,
prenons le temps de nous restaurer.
Louis,
n'allez pas vous faire remarquer.
Madame,
prenez donc votre déjeuner,
nous repartons
dans quelques minutes.
Mes amies, je me présente,
monsieur Durand,
intendant de la baronne de Korff.
Vous me ferez un grand plaisir
de partager avec moi
ce nectar
des terres de Bourgogne.
Ma foi il fait bien chaud,
votre nectar est le bienvenu.
On trinque à quoi ?
- À monsieur Durand.
Nous pourrions trinquer au roi,
qu'en pensez-vous ?
Le roi,
je l'ai toujours beaucoup aimé,
le grand Louis.
Je l'aime bien aussi
notre souverain.
A-t-il l'appui
de son peuple ?
C'est notre roi,
il a toujours été bon pour nous.
À Paris, tout le monde,
ne partage pas votre avis.
Que connaissent-ils
de notre vie ceux de Paris ?
Là-bas,
plus personne travaille.
C'est sûr que c'est dur.
Nous, à la campagne,
notre terre donne toujours.
Attention les gouttes.
La reine,
est-elle dans votre estime ?
Non, la poule.
C'est une tête à vent
qui vide les caisses
et couche
avec tout ce qu'elle peut.
Il doit pas rigoler
tous les jours
le pauvre bouc
qu'est marié avec elle.
Je vous laisse le rouquin,
mesdames,
ce fut un plaisir.
On aurait pu faire mieux.
Je suis certain que tout le plaisir
aurait été pour moi.
Une autre fois,
peut-être.
Une des directions prévue
était la route de Verdun.
C'est tout proche
de la frontière luxembourgeoise.
Vous connaissez
bien mal votre roi.
Jamais Louis XVI
ne ferait appel à une armée extérieure
pour tirer
sur son propre peuple.
Mon cousin est un pacifiste.
- Pas sa femme.
Espérons donc
que Marie-Antoinette
ne soit pas responsable
de l'issue du voyage.
J'ai également envoyé Bayon
sur la route de Montmédy,
j'ai le pressentiment
que le roi y passera.
Il y a pire,
dans les rues de Paris,
les esprits s'échauffent.
J'ai bien peur que la monarchie douce que
nous avions imaginée ne fasse long feu.
Si nous ne contrôlons pas le roi,
nous ne contrôlerons plus rien.
Il faudrait anticiper
pour ne pas terminer sur l'échafaud.
C'est bien mon avis, Bailly.
C'est pourquoi vous me verrez bientôt
paraître comme ceci devant vous,
en Philippe Égalité.
Tandis qu'à Paris la nouvelle
se répand très rapidement,
les cavaliers de La Fayette
sont déjà partis aux quatre vents.
Lancés à bride abattue,
ils mettent le pays en état d'alerte.
Avec, sur la lourde berline,
un avantage décisif, la vitesse.
Vous ne croyez tout de même pas
que vos sujets vous sont restés fidèles ?
Si, voyez-vous.
Je suis sûr qu'une partie
non-négligeable des Français
soutient
toujours la monarchie.
À la bonne heure !
Vos gens vont donc pouvoir
nous venir en aide, n'est-ce pas ?
Le peuple français
ne nous est pas hostile.
Ces lavandières vous ont tourné la tête.
Seule l'armée de mon frère
pourrait rétablir votre autorité.
Votre frère !
Votre frère ne nous a donné
aucune nouvelle.
Lorsque nous lui avons fait part
de notre désir de quitter les tuileries,
il nous a abandonnés.
De plus, je ne ferais jamais tirer
sur mes sujets et vous le savez.
Votre bon peuple est manipulé
par un ramassis de sanguinaires
prêts à nous égorger.
Une guerre civile n'apportera pas
la paix en France.
Qui vous parle de paix ?
Il faut vaincre nos ennemis.
Nous ne ferons pas
l'économie d'une guerre.
L'intervention de la noblesse étrangère
ferait de moi un roi sous tutelle.
Je ne dois ma couronne qu'à Dieu.
Vous ne comprenez rien
à la politique.
Un roi qui fait la guerre
à son peuple est un tyran.
Moi, je veux aider les Français
à vivre mieux.
Si j'arrive à gagner ta confiance
quant au but de ce voyage,
j'aurai accompli
un miracle, en somme.
En fuyant la capitale,
le roi laisse une France orpheline.
À Paris, la vacance du pouvoir plonge
les révolutionnaires dans le désarroi.
Désemparés,
Robespierre,
Orléans,
Desmoulins et quelques autres,
cherchent une réponse politique.
Je l'ai, La Fayette
m'a confié la lettre que le roi a laissée
dans sa chambre avant de partir.
Bien Robespierre
et que nous raconte donc mon gros cousin ?
Lorsque le roi a pu espérer
de voir renaître l'ordre et le bonheur
par les moyens employés
par l'ordre assemblé,
aucun sacrifice ne lui a coûté.
Il n'aurait même pas argué
du défaut de liberté
dont il est privé
depuis le mois d'octobre 1789.
Il ne va pas nous faire croire qu'il est
venu habiter les Tuileries de lui-même.
Laisse parler Camille,
citoyen d'Orléans.
Le roi a le droit de s'expliquer.
Aujourd'hui,
que le résultat de toutes ces opérations
est de voir la royauté détruite,
les propriétés volées,
la sûreté des personnes compromises,
une anarchie complète
dans tout l'Empire.
C'est une trahison !
Le roi abandonne son peuple
et en plus il nous donne des leçons.
Les propriétés volées,
mais non,
c'est une juste répartition
des richesses.
Louis XVI n'a jamais été hostile
aux réformes, Marat.
Sa fuite est à la fois
un aveu d'impuissance et une trahison.
Nous devons donc
le reprendre et le punir,
mais on ne peut
se passer du roi.
Nous n'avons nullement besoin d'un roi
si nous instaurons la République.
Marat,
tu es incorrigible.
Crois-tu que la France soit prête
à passer en une nuit
de la monarchie
à la République ?
Le roi part, la République arrive.
- Tais-toi Marat.
Tu fais honte
à notre révolution.
C'est Louis XVI
qui a donné la parole au tiers état
alors si une République doit exister,
elle se fera par la volonté du peuple.
Citoyens, le roi
nous envoie un message très clair.
Il veut une nouvelle constitution
qui ne saurait être la nôtre.
L'exécutif doit être totalement
soumis au législatif.
Dans ce cas,
il faudra se résigner à la République.
Non, pas se résigner,
madame Roland.
La République doit être instaurée
par la violence.
Il faut couper
les têtes des aristocrates.
La Seine doit devenir un fleuve rouge,
alors le peuple atteindra le bonheur.
Robespierre a raison,
en faussant compagnie à ses geôliers,
le roi cherche à gagner
la citadelle de Montmédy.
De là, protégé
par les armées du marquis de Bouillé,
il a l'intention de négocier
avec l'Assemblée
une constitution
qui lui soit favorable.
On ne sauve pas un trône
en raisonnant des ânes.
Je suis un pacifiste.
Je n'ai livré qu'une seule bataille.
Celle contre les Anglais afin de
libérer les Amériques de leur joug.
Pour quel résultat ?
Certains de vos sujets, maintenant,
réclament une République, bravo !
Vous n'y êtes pas, ma femme.
Ce peuple d'Amérique devenu libre,
a su forger une grande nation.
Nous pouvons aussi
faire notre métamorphose
en établissant une monarchie
constitutionnelle.
Les sanguinaires voudront votre tête.
Tuer le roi,
c'est tuer Dieu et c'est leur objectif.
J'ai confiance en mon peuple.
Certains députés du tiers partagent
des points de vue proches des nôtres.
Vous êtes le roi.
Vos sujets
vous doivent obéissance
et voilà
comment se dirige un pays.
Pas de nos jours, ma femme.
Les hommes sont éduqués,
le peuple revendique des droits
et certains privilèges
d'une caste néfaste contrastent par trop
avec la dureté
de la vie de mon peuple.
Nous ne jouons plus,
je présume.
Moi aussi,
j'aime le peuple
et je sais que la noblesse
nous a lâchement abandonnés,
mais je ne suis pas naïve.
Même si vous gardez toujours secrète
notre destination,
retrouverons-nous
les hussards du duc de Choiseul
à Pont-de-Somme-Vesle ?
- Absolument ma mie.
Heureusement, votre coiffeur nous
a prévenu de la perfidie de La Fayette.
Brave Léonard.
Sa fidélité
l'aura obligé à fuir également.
- Ça fait des heures
qu'on est là à attendre.
Alors ?
- Toujours rien en vue, monseigneur.
J'ai dû partir si vite
que j'ai gardé la redingote de mon frère.
Croyez-vous que je pourrais repasser
pour la lui rendre ?
N'y pensez même pas,
mon brave.
À cette heure, La Fayette
a dû perquisitionner votre appartement
et il n'est déjà plus le vôtre.
Je n'ai pas
de linge de rechange.
Votre perruque est de travers,
je peux m'en occuper,
j'ai le nécessaire sur moi.
Tandis que les fugitifs
accumulent du retard,
les cavaliers de La Fayette,
rapides comme l'éclair,
gagnent du terrain.
L'avance confortable de la berline
est en train de fondre
comme neige au soleil.
Un cheval frais.
- Amène un cheval frais.
Je suis envoyé par l'Assemblée nationale
afin d'apporter un message au roi.
Avez-vous vu berline
avec quelqu'un lui ressemblant
et plusieurs femmes
et des enfants ?
Oui, j'ai vu passer
une famille ce matin.
Elle partait pour la Russie,
en direction de Meaux.
Bonjour Lucile.
- Bonjour Maximilien.
L'Assemblée nationale s'est réunie
et les décrets ont été votés.
Le roi et sa famille
sont officiellement en état d'arrestation.
L'arrestation doit être suivie
de la destitution du roi
et de la proclamation
de la République par l'Assemblée.
Il nous faut une République fraternelle,
de citoyens libres et égaux en droits.
Je ne suis pas de votre avis,
madame Roland.
Le retour du roi
est nécessaire à notre mission.
Un aussi grand pays que la France,
n'est pas mûr pour la République.
Le roi n'est pas encore arrêté,
Maximilien.
Peut-être,
reviendra-t-il de lui-même à Paris.
Même si elle n'a pas encore
convaincu Robespierre,
l'idée de République,
hier impensable,
fait aujourd'hui son chemin
dans l'esprit des révolutionnaires.
- Quelqu'un pour les chevaux.
Aglaé, venez,
allons nous soulager
et donnons à ces dames
le temps de se mettre à l'aise.
Je ne veux pas uriner
comme une fille.
Je sais mon ange.
Bientôt vous pourrez revêtir
votre uniforme de capitaine.
En attendant,
relevez votre robe.
Il ne faut pas
faire uriner votre fille,
il faut aller là-bas pour ça.
Vous m'avez entendu ?
- Oui, mon brave.
Vous, ici, Sire.
C'est un honneur
de vous avoir dans mon modeste relais,
faites attention
à ne pas vous faire reconnaître,
certains, ici,
nous ne sont déjà plus royalistes.
Je vous avais dit, père,
que ce costume ne vous convenait pas.
Il ne faut pas nous faire voir
pour ne pas être reconnus.
Venez, les enfants.
- Quel mal à cela ?
Paris est loin
et vos chers Français vous aiment,
n'est-ce pas ?
Évidemment,
mais les idées de la Révolution
ont troublé bien des esprits.
Mon pain !
- Je reviens.
Pardon,
excusez-moi.
Tenez, Sire, de la part de ma femme,
mais hâtez-vous.
Si on vous savait en fuite,
ce serait l'émeute.
Croyez-vous qu'il y a un risque
à être reconnu de vos gens ?
La prise de la Bastille
a tout changé et maintenant,
tout le monde se dit exploité.
Je ne comprends plus ce monde, Sire.
Partons pour ne pas faire courir
de risques à ce brave homme.
À mort les aristos !
En-avant,
au galop, allez !
Ils font quoi ?
Je n'en ai aucune idée,
mais c'est très mauvais signe.
Les paysans du Pont-de-Somme-Vesle
se questionnent sur
notre présence si près du village.
Je suis le duc de Choiseul,
commandant ce détachement de hussards.
Que puis-je faire pour vous ?
- Que faites-vous près de notre bois ?
Nous attendons
le passage d'un trésor.
La solde de la Garde nationale
que nous devons escorter
jusqu'à Sainte-Ménehould.
Pourquoi ces armes ?
Vous n'êtes pas là
pour récolter l'impôt qu'on n'a pas payé ?
Je ne sais pas
de quoi vous parlez.
Tu nous prends
pour des idiots avec ton trésor.
Déjà, hier, vous étiez là,
à rôder près de notre bois.
Pourquoi ils ont dit le tocsin ?
C'est l'exécution
si on ne paie pas les droits de la terre.
On prévient les villageois
des alentours de votre présence ici.
De quoi parle-t-il ?
Cessez de vous agiter
comme une girouette.
La famille royale
a plus de quatre heures de retard
sur l'horaire prévu.
Les ordres sont d'attendre la berline.
Si la berline ne vient pas ?
Le voyage avait déjà été reporté
et s'ils se sont faits arrêtés ?
Pas de ça,
ce serait la fin,
notre perte à tous.
Aussi, si nous restons ici,
ces paysans n'ont pas l'air bien amical.
L'escorte de Choiseul
est indispensable aux fugitifs,
mais le jeune duc manque
cruellement d'expérience.
Le destin de la monarchie
est pourtant entre ses mains.
Très bien,
nous partons.
Ce voyage, prend-il
une mauvaise tournure père ?
Non, pas du tout.
J'ai hâte de vous mettre
à l'abri à Montmédy.
Montmédy,
c'est en France cela ?
Oui, juste à la frontière.
Pourquoi ne pas aller chez l'Empereur
comme le voudrait maman ?
Si je passais la frontière on m'accuserait
de trahir mon pays, Mousseline.
Que ferons-nous à Montmédy ?
Vous attendrez en sécurité
que je termine la rédaction
d'une nouvelle constitution
avec des délégués
de l'Assemblée nationale.
Maman pense
que ce n'est qu'utopie.
C'est pour cela que je l'ai tenue
à l'écart de mon entreprise.
Cette constitution souderait la confiance
qu'un peuple doit avoir en son souverain.
Et éviterait la guerre ?
- Exactement.
Louis XVI aimait par dessus tout
ces moments partagés avec ses enfants.
Il s'est attaché
à leur donner une éducation
qui les ouvre
sur le monde de demain,
mais au fond de lui,
se cachait une immense blessure.
Louis-Joseph,
mon fils aîné,
mon fils chéri.
La maladie a rendu difforme
la colonne vertébrale du dauphin, Sire.
Afin de la remettre en état,
il faudrait qu'il porte un corset.
Je doute de l'efficacité
de ce procédé.
Sire, vous qui êtes un scientifique,
qu'il me soit permis de vous dire
que vous devriez faire
davantage confiance à la médecine,
votre majesté.
Père,
Je tenais à vous rassurer.
Je n'ai pas peur de mourir,
vous savez, père.
Si je vous montrais
cette merveille de montgolfière.
Il faut d'abord gonfler le ballon
en réchauffant l'air à l'intérieur.
Ensuite, les passagers prennent
place dans la nacelle, ici
et pour s'envoler,
ils doivent lâcher du lest.
Père,
peut-on aller jusqu'à la lune ?
Un jour, certainement,
cela sera possible.
Mon amour !
Ne vous inquiétez pas
mon petit ange.
Sire,
on vous réclame à l'Assemblée.
Une délégation du tiers état
conduite par Bailly demande à vous voir.
N'est-il donc pas un père
parmi ces gens-là ?
Malgré l'acharnement
des médecins,
l'état de Louis-Joseph
empira jusqu'à ce 4 juin 1789,
où le premier dauphin succomba
à la tuberculose osseuse.
Malden, que se passe-t-il ?
- Cet idiot a fait un écart.
Je suis désolé,
monsieur Durand.
L'essieu est tordu,
il y en a au moins pour deux heures,
au travail.
Est-ce que ce postillon l'a fait exprès ?
Veut-il nous retarder ?
Nous a-t-on reconnus ?
Allons,
Louis, du sang-froid.
Le trésor ne passera pas
aujourd'hui,
vous recevrez demain
de nouveaux ordres.
Apportez ce billet
au capitaine d'Andoins à Sainte-Ménéhould
afin qu'il démobilise ce dragon
pour aujourd'hui.
Moi ? Pourquoi moi ?
- Parce que je ne veux plus vous voir !
Si Choiseul avait attendu
une heure de plus,
l'Histoire se serait peut-être
écrite autrement.
- En-avant, messieurs.
- Hussards, en-avant.
- Bravo !
Vous n'aviez pas fait
autant d'exercices depuis longtemps.
En route, maintenant.
Choiseul doit
se faire un sang d'encre.
Malden, vissez bien l'écrou,
- Oui.
Voilà, parfait !
Équipage inadapté,
itinéraire mal évalué
et relais qui partent avant l'heure,
l'organisation de la fuite du roi
relevait de l'amateurisme.
Alors que l'inquiétude s'invitait
dans la berline royale,
à Paris,
la confusion gagnait les esprits.
En quelques heures,
les patriotes les plus virulents
avaient réussi à convaincre le peuple
que le roi avait quitté la France,
qu'i allait prendre la tête
de la contre-révolution,
qu'il avait trahi son peuple
et violé son serment.
Qu'en est-il de notre rêve d'un monde
sans pauvres, sans riches ?
Un monde simplement
d'hommes égaux en droits.
Cette fuite met à mal nos idéaux.
Avec son journal, Marat et ses amis
brouillent l'esprit de la Révolution.
Marat est un exalté,
personne n'accorde de crédit
à ses vociférations.
Si le roi est arrêté,
les monarchies d'Europe ne vont-elles pas
nous déclarer la guerre ?
Lucile, si elles avaient voulu l'aider,
elles l'auraient déjà fait.
La question est plutôt
que va-t-on faire de lui s'il est arrêté ?
Il sera décapité, bien sûr.
Nous ne voulons pas la mort du roi,
mais une République juste et équitable.
On s'est battus contre la barbarie,
pour l'égalité des hommes.
Pas pour que le sang coule
par notre faute.
C'est ça, oui,
mais en attendant,
si le roi passe à l'étranger,
il reviendra
pour nous massacrer avec une armée.
Ton amitié avec
le duc d'Orléans t'égare, Danton.
Jamais le roi ne ferait tirer
sur son peuple,
sa femme,
par contre.
Pourrait-on imposer à ce roi suspendu
une constitution à notre convenance ?
Oui, on pourrait
tenter l'expérience
à la condition de se débarrasser
de La Fayette et consorts.
Sans doute
suis-je le seul à penser de la sorte.
Tu te trompes,
Maximilien.
En s'enfuyant,
le roi a fait sonner
le glas de la monarchie.
Je suis d'accord,
c'est trop tard pour Louis XVI,
mais le peuple aime le roi.
Il aurait pu être
le meilleur roi pour une révolution,
mais il n'a pas compris les enjeux.
Si vous dites vrai,
mes amis,
si l'on ne peut plus
sauver la royauté
alors il faudra
prendre l'Assemblée
sinon on ne fera pas
l'économie d'une guerre.
Il n'y aura pas
que les jours du roi qui seront comptés.
N'est-ce pas ici
que nous relayons ?
Il pleut, il pleut bergère,
rentre tes blancs.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Où est Choiseul ?
Il n'y avait personne, Sire,
ni Choiseul, ni ses hussards.
Pourquoi n'avez-vous pas laissé
Fersen nous accompagner ?
Lui, aurait su trouver les hussards.
- Laissez Fersen là où il est !
Père,
où sont les hussards ?
De quoi parlez-vous donc,
mon ange ?
Je sais que nous n'allons pas
à une fête costumée.
Je vous ai entendu parler avec père
des hussards de monsieur de Choiseul.
Ils devaient être là
à nous attendre.
Au prochain relais, mon fils.
En attendant, remontez dans la berline.
Je dois m'entretenir
avec votre mère.
Si vous me racontiez les derniers exploits
de monsieur de La Pérouse.
- Nous sommes perdus.
Loin de là,
nous allons faire route
jusqu'au prochain relais,
Choiseul doit y être.
Je veux voir ce beau sourire
sur votre divin visage.
Rien n'est perdu,
ma femme.
J'ai peur pour toi.
J'ai déjà vu
cette expression sur ton visage,
ma bien-aimée.
Des médisantes
vous surnommaient madame Déficit
lorsque tu es devenue la femme
la plus méprisée de France.
Deux phénomènes ont contribué
au rejet de la reine.
Son mépris de la vieille aristocratie
au profit d'une cour de son choix
et le fait
que le roi n'a jamais eu de maîtresse,
ces favorites sur lesquelles
se cristallisent d'ordinaire
les jalousies des courtisans.
Nous devons parler.
Je vous écoute.
Vous faites aussi de moi
le cocu couronné,
mais j'ai confiance en vous
et n'y accorde pas d'importance.
Pourquoi m'accabler ?
Qu'ai-je fait à notre peuple
pour être affublée de ces sobriquets,
tels madame Déficit
ou la poule d'Autriche ?
Le peuple n'y est pour rien,
mais il croit ce qu'on lui dit.
Vos dépenses irritent l'opinion
et nourrissent l'hostilité,
d'où ce "Madame Déficit".
Puisque l'amour du peuple
en dépend,
je suis renoncerai
donc au Petit Trianon.
Voilà une très sage décision.
C'est agir en reine
que de renoncer à certains privilèges.
Le peuple de France
peut encore vous aimer.
Il suffit de gestes simples.
Vous montrer à Paris, faire quelques
actes publics de philanthropie.
Je n'aime pas être impopulaire.
- Vous ne l'êtes pas à mes yeux.
Si vous agissez
en reine de France et non plus de salon,
ils vous reviendront tels des enfants
réclamant le câlin de leur mère.
Je ne m'appartiens donc pas.
- C'est vrai.
Le corps de la reine est politique,
mais je ne peux vous laisser croire
qu'être la jolie femme la plus à la mode
est un titre plus enviable
que celui de reine de France.
Capitaine d'Andoins ?
- Oui.
Il y a un drôle qui arrive vers nous.
- J'ai entendu.
Capitaine d'Andoins ?
« Il n'y a pas d'apparence
que le trésor passera aujourd'hui. »
Ce n'est pas pour aujourd'hui les gars.
Vous avez quartier libre.
- Merci, mon capitaine.
- Allez en selle, à la taverne.
Pourquoi Choiseul
n'était-il pas au rendez-vous ?
Ce pourrait-il qu'il m'ait trahi ?
Non, c'est impossible.
Alors quoi ?
Qui ?
Attention madame.
Louis, laissez-moi vous prêter main-forte.
- Merci, ma sœur.
Si Léonard nous avait trahis.
- Allons donc !
Pour quelle raison
aurait-il fait cela ?
Il jouait bien double jeu avec La Fayette.
Oui, mais c'était
sur nos ordres.
Madame de Tourzel,
elle aurait bien pu.
Vous divaguez, ma femme,
personne ne nous a trahis
et certainement pas
la gouvernante des enfants.
Choiseul doit être au prochain relais,
calmez-vous.
Voilà 19 h
que la famille royale est sur la route.
Après avoir relayé 21 fois
et parcouru 287 kilomètres,
tout le monde est exténué.
Toi, j'ai besoin de six chevaux frais.
- Mes chevaux sont aux champs.
Va les chercher et fais vite,
une berline arrive
pour relayer d'ici peu.
Que faites-vous là ?
Je croyais que le trésor
ne passait plus aujourd'hui.
La berline me suit
et sera là d'ici peu,
où sont vos hommes ?
Certains sont partis
et les autres ne sont plus capables
d'assurer la protection du roi.
Tenez, j'ai reçu l'ordre de démobilisation
de monsieur Choiseul.
Vos ordres étaient
d'attendre la berline.
Pas aujourd'hui,
vous avez cinq heures de retard
et on Choiseul m'a ordonné
de quitter mon poste.
Vous êtes bien chargés,
où allez-vous comme ça ?
En Russie, nous emmenons
la baronne de Korff et sa suite.
Valory ?
Toi, ne crève pas les bêtes
dans la côte de l'Argonne.
D'accord.
Encore des aristocrates
qui émigrent avec leurs bijoux.
Ce n'est pas
le prince de Condé
qui a fait un aller-retour en France ?
Tu as vu la livrée jaune des cochers ?
Moi, tant que je loue mes chevaux.
Il y a des hommes
qui nous attendent Dun et à Mouzay,
et même le régiment royal
allemand à Stenay.
Nous devons garder
notre sang-froid.
Sire,
vos ordres ont été mal pris.
D'Andoins, où sont vos dragons ?
- Partez, Sire, pressez-vous.
Vous êtes perdu
si vous ne vous hâtez.
Malden,
en-avant, maintenant !
Les chevaux sont prêts,
monsieur Durand.
Il reste une chance
si nous rejoignons Varennes
et les hussards
du fils du marquis de Bouillé.
Il aura fallu cette adversité
pour que tu te jettes enfin dans mes bras.
Je te protégerai,
j'en fais le serment.
Un cheval.
Drouet, le maître de poste,
que se passe-t-il ?
Tu as vu une berline verte
avec des roues jaunes ?
Il y a une heure, oui.
C'est le roi, la reine, madame Isabelle,
le Dauphin et madame Royale.
C'est une baronne russe.
- Tu as vérifié les passeports ?
Lis ça.
Dis-moi si tu le reconnais.
Amène mon cheval,
je vais passer par le Pas de Vaches
et les rejoindre à Varennes.
Tu as plutôt intérêt
ou je ne donne pas cher de ta tête.
Préviens La Hure,
on ne sera pas trop de deux, allez !
D'accord !
Personne n'attendait la berline
au relais prévu,
personne aux alentours.
Le roi pensait pourtant
y trouver les pelisses vertes
des hussards de Lauzun.
Rien, ni Bouillé ni Choiseul,
ni Goguelat
ni même Léonard.
- On y est presque.
En fait, le relais avait été dressé
au mauvais endroit,
mais ça,
Louis XVI ne pouvait pas le savoir.
Bouillé n'est pas là.
Tu as vu les hussards ?
- Non plus.
Le relais ?
- Je ne l'ai pas vu non plus, majesté.
Je vais aller
vers la ligne basse.
C'est impossible nous ne pouvons pas
échouer si près du but.
Est-ce ici
que l'on relaie les chevaux ?
- Passez votre chemin.
Calmez-vous, Louis.
Venez m'aider
à bloquer la rue,
le roi est ici en fuite.
Une berline arrive avec la famille royale
qui est en route pour l'étranger.
Allez, venez, venez !
- Oui, on y va.
Attendez,
apportez le canon.
Attendez !
Ils arrivent.
Arrêtez !
Vos papiers.
C'est ainsi que l'on s'adresse
à des voyageurs fourbus, jeune homme.
Vos papiers,
s'il vous plaît.
Madame la baronne, s'il vous plaît.
Merci.
Ce passeport n'est pas réglementaire,
je n'y vois pas le cachet de l'Assemblée.
Vous devriez savoir qu'il n'est pas exigé
sur un passeport, mon brave.
Mes amis, moi, Drouet,
vous affirme que l'homme
que nous avons devant nous,
n'est autre
que le roi Louis XVI.
C'est le roi !
- Gardez votre calme, je m'en occupe.
Je ne sais
quelle mouche vous a piqué,
mais vous vous méprenez.
Je suis Monsieur Durand,
l'intendant de madame la baronne
de Korff, ici, présente,
et je vous prie de nous laisser passer.
Moi, je dis que vous êtes le roi
et que votre route s'arrête à Varennes.
La Hure va faire sonner le tocsin.
- Bien, citoyen.
C'est l'heure de réveiller la révolution.
Dites-moi, monsieur Drouet,
y aurait-il une autorité compétente
dans ce charmant village ?
Une autorité qui nous permettrait
de sortir de cette grotesque méprise.
Il y a bien monsieur Sauce.
- Monsieur Sauce ?
Oui, c'est l'épicier
qui vend des bougies,
il est aussi procureur-syndic
et adjoint au maire.
Rendez-vous utile Drouet,
cherchez monsieur Sauce,
nous n'avons que trop attendu.
Toi, tu me les surveilles.
- Bien, d'accord.
- Avec ce vacarme,
Bouillé sera là d'un instant à l'autre.
Le fils du marquis de Bouillé
se trouve bien à Varennes,
mais effrayé par l'agitation
inhabituelle de cette nuit,
il n'ose intervenir.
- Laissez-passer.
Monsieur Sauce,
procureur-syndic de Varennes,
que puis-je faire pour vous?
Cher Monsieur Sauce,
nous sommes victimes
d'un ridicule méprise.
Cet homme m'accuse d'être le roi
et nous empêche de continuer notre route.
Je suis monsieur Durand,
l'intendant de madame
la baronne de Korff, ici présente,
avec ses deux filles,
sa dame de compagnie et sa gouvernante.
Nous allons à un bal costumé.
Oui,
Aglaé.
Nous irons dès que monsieur Sauce
nous laissera partir.
Nous allons en Russie
rejoindre monsieur le baron
qui a organisé un grand bal costumé
en l'honneur de sa femme.
Nous vous serions gré
d'aider cet homme à retrouver la raison
et nous permettre
de poursuivre notre voyage.
Oui.
Certes, ce sont des gens
de haute considération,
mais de là à penser que
ce monsieur Durand n'est autre que le roi.
Je vous dis
que cet homme est le roi,
s'il part,
vous serez accusé de haute trahison.
Vous parlez bien haut, Drouet.
Imaginez
que vous vous mépreniez.
Ces gens me semblent sincères
et leur passeport est en règle,
pourquoi les retenir ?
La frontière est proche
et le roi n'est pas là par hasard,
il peut la passer
pour rejoindre les armées étrangères.
Si vous tenez à votre tête,
monsieur Sauce, retenez cet homme.
Mon bon monsieur Sauce,
pouvons-nous repartir enfin ?
Je vous demande quelques instants,
la situation est complexe.
Vraiment, monsieur Sauce,
ai-je l'air du roi de France ?
Si Monsieur Durand est le roi,
moi, je suis la reine alors.
Moi, l'impératrice de Russie.
Permettez-moi de vous offrir
mon modeste logis,
je ne veux vous faire
courrir aucun risque.
Empêchez-vous madame la baronne
de poursuivre son voyage ?
En aucun cas,
je veux juste prendre
le temps de la réflexion.
Madame la baronne
a des amis très puissants à Paris,
les connaissant,
je n'aimerais pas
être à votre place.
Madame la baronne,
vous serez plus
au confortable à l'intérieur.
Bouillé et ses hommes
ne sont pas loin,
nous leur laisserons le temps
d'arriver en acceptant l'hospitalité.
Si Bouillé ne vient pas ?
Il va venir,
le tocsin va lui donner l'alerte.
Le tocsin sonne
depuis longtemps déjà,
pourquoi n'est-il pas là,
ce Bouillé de malheur ?
Monsieur Sauce,
je vous répète que je ne suis pas le roi,
seulement, monsieur Durand.
Si vous insistez vous allez devenir
la risée de Varennes,
et qui sait,
bientôt de toute la France.
Je sais,
mais je ne fais qu'appliquer la procédure.
Dans de tels cas,
nous avons bien compris cela.
Bonsoir.
Espérons que Monsieur Drouet
ne va pas confondre le roi
avec d'autres voyageurs cette nuit,
vous n'aurez plus assez de place
dans votre logis
pour offrir l'hospitalité,
Monsieur Sauce.
Je vais envoyer
un émissaire à Paris.
Faites donc, faites donc,
et apportez nous de quoi nous restaurer,
vous savez
que le roi a grand appétit,
c'est le seul point commun
que j'ai avec lui.
Madame Sauce.
Je sais, le juge Destez,
lui, il a séjourné à Versailles.
Il pourra nous dire si vous êtes vraiment
Louis XVI ou monsieur Durand.
Tout est perdu cette fois,
n'est-ce pas ?
Je ne sais où se cache Bouillé
et ne comprend pas notre isolement.
Je suis désolé de vous avoir entraînée
dans cette épreuve.
Vous permettez ?
Quitter Paris est une décision
que nous avons prise ensemble,
vous n'avez rien à vous reprocher.
- Si je n'avais pas renvoyé Fersen.
Sa présence n'aurait rien changé,
il aurait été lui aussi prisonnier.
Peut-être que nous aurions dû
aller en terre d'Autriche,
retrouver votre nécessaire de toilette.
C'est vous qui avez raison,
un souverain ne fait pas
la guerre à ses sujets.
Comme vous êtes belle !
Tant que nous ne sommes pas
reconnus officiellement,
il reste une chance de repartir,
n'est-ce pas ?
J'ai apporté du linge
pour les enfants de madame la baronne.
- Les amis, sortons.
Si, laissons l'équipage
de la baronne de Korff
se restaurer en paix.
Allez,
allez, allez !
Tenez, madame.
- Merci, madame.
Madame Sauce ?
- Oui.
Nous devons reprendre
notre route au plus vite,
monsieur le baron est très malade
et souhaite voir sa femme
et ses enfants une dernière fois.
Vous comprenez ?
- Oui.
J'entends bien,
madame,
mais je ne peux rien faire
contre l'autorité de mon mari.
En aucun cas,
je ne vous demande d'aller contre,
mais de lui faire
entendre raison,
de permettre
à la baronne de Korff et à ses enfants
d'entourer une dernière fois le baron.
Quelle serait votre détresse si on vous
empêchait d'assister une dernière fois
l'être que vous aimez ?
Je suis désolée, madame Rochet,
mais je ne peux rien faire.
Madame Sauce,
je vous supplie de me croire.
Je suis désolée.
Endormez-vous,
ma chérie, endormez-vous.
Poussez-vous !
Laissez-nous passer !
Monsieur Durand,
le juge Destez.
Sire.
Oui,
je suis votre roi.
Voilà la reine et ma famille.
Je viens vivre parmi vous
dans le sein de mes enfants
que je n'abandonne pas.
- Non, non !
Vous fuyez à l'étranger.
Je suis le père de la nation,
je vais simplement à Montmédy
et ne vous permets pas
de m'accuser d'abandonner mon pays.
Au milieu des baïonnettes,
nous risquions de mourir à Paris,
ma famille et moi.
Sire, vous me voyez troublé,
votre majesté dans mon épicerie.
Mon bon Monsieur Sauce,
faites-nous escorter jusqu'à Montmédy
par la Garde nationale,
vous serez rassuré
sur nos intentions de rester en France.
Le roi ne va pas prendre
la tête de la contre-révolution,
mais négocier avec l'Assemblée
afin de mettre sur pied
une nouvelle constitution
qui assurerait durablement
l'avenir du peuple de France.
Je ne puis prendre la décision seul,
je dois en informer les municipaux.
C'est le roi !
- C'est le roi !
Sire.
C'est donc la fin,
on nous a abandonnés.
Les hussards !
Je suis le capitaine Goguelat.
Laissez-passer les hussards.
Laissez-moi passer.
- Allez, reculez !
Reculez !
Laissez-passer !
Laissez-moi passer !
Goguelat !
Nous sommes sauvés.
Sire, mes hommes sont dehors,
ils sont prêts à vous ouvrir un passage.
Choiseul ?
Pourquoi n'était-il pas au relais ?
Choiseul a attendu cinq heures
votre passage,
ses hommes étaient exténués,
il aura tant attisé la curiosité des gens.
Peu importe,
il n'avait pas à déserter son poste.
Quand partons-nous ?
Mes hussards sont là
en ordre de marche.
Je vais faire ouvrir le chemin
et nous venons vous chercher.
La famille royale va sortir,
formez une haie pour assurer leur passage.
À Varennes,
nous ne recevons pas d'ordres.
Hussards, pour le roi,
en formation.
Maman ?
Ça va capitaine ?
Venez.
Que s'est-il passé,
Goguelat ?
Ils m'ont tiré dessus.
Venez.
Nous ne pourrons pas sortir d'ici
sans faire couler le sang ?
Nous sommes prêts
à mourir pour vous, Sire.
Je n'en doute pas,
mais je ne donnerai jamais l'ordre
de faire tirer sur la foule.
Choiseul vient d'arriver
à Varennes, Sire,
mes hussards et ses dragons peuvent
vous ouvrir un passage.
Pouvez-vous me garantir
la sécurité de ma famille ?
Père, je pourrais mettre
mon costume de capitaine des gardes
et nous faire sortir d'ici.
Foutre ! Il doit bien exister un moyen
de sortir de cette épicerie.
Le roi est ici ?
- Oui, citoyen, à l'étage.
- Laissez passer le citoyen.
- Il ne passe pas.
Capitaine Bayon.
Commandant le septième bataillon
de la Garde nationale.
Je suis porteur
d'un ordre du général La Fayette.
Un décret de l'Assemblée
ordonnant votre retour à Paris.
Oui, il faut ramener
le roi à Paris.
Vous, Romeuf.
Mon ancien écuyer,
que je croisais tous les jours
aux Tuileries avec tant de plaisir,
que n'avez-vous déchiré
cet odieux décret ?
À Paris,
on est au bord de l'insurrection.
Si vous ne revenez pas,
des flots de sang couleront
et vous en serez responsables.
M'accuser de vouloir
faire verser le sang de mes sujets.
Il n'y a plus de sujets,
mais des citoyens.
S'il n'y a plus de sujets,
il n'y a plus
de roi en France.
Père, si nous avions pris la montgolfière.
Nous serions déjà arrivés,
mon ange.
Bien sûr qu'il reste un roi,
un grand roi qui a toujours voulu
le bonheur des Français
au point de leur éviter toute guerre,
toute répression.
Un grand roi que vous vous apprêtez
à livrer à des bourreaux sanguinaires.
Un grand roi
que vous regretterez.
Mon devoir est de mourir
à ses pieds.
Un grand roi
que j'ai toujours aimé
et que j'aime aujourd'hui
plus que jamais.
Relevez-vous, Madame.
Ôtez-vous de mon chemin,
je vous ai déjà dit
que le roi ne fuit pas.
- Poussez-vous !
- Le roi arrive !
- Vive la République !
- Laissez-le parler.
Peuple de France,
vous êtes le plus glorieux
des peuples.
Je vous aime
et je suis fier d'être votre roi.
J'ai entendu votre appel.
Votre malheur est grand
et je comprends votre désarroi,
mais ne vous laissez pas guider
par les intrigants.
Fiez-vous à votre jugement
et vous gagnerez
véritablement votre liberté,
mon peuple de France.
Un an plus tard,
la République sera proclamée.
Le 21 janvier 1793,
à l'issue d'un procès inédit,
Louis XVI est condamné à la guillotine
par 361 voix contre 360.
Le duc d'Orléans,
devenu Philippe Égalité,
a voté la mort de son cousin.
Je meurs innocent
de tous les crimes qu'on m'impute.
Je pardonne
aux auteurs de ma mort
et je prie Dieu
que le sang que vous allez répandre
ne retombe pas sur la France.
Enfermée dans la prison
du Temple,
Marie-Antoinette est décapitée
neuf mois plus tard.
Le dauphin meurt de maladie
à l'âge de 10 ans
après trois longues années
de captivité.
L'unique survivante,
madame Royale,
est échangée avec l'Autriche
contre trois commissaires,
parmi lesquels Drouet,
responsable de l'arrestation
de Varennes.
Monarchiste parlementaire,
le marquis de La Fayette
est déclaré traître à la patrie en 1792.
Il émigre avant d'être fait prisonnier
par l'Armée autrichienne.
Jean-Paul Marat,
fondateur du journal L'ami du peuple
et porte-parole des sans-culottes,
est assassiné le 13 juillet 1793
par Charlotte Corday.
Victime de la terreur,
Camille Desmoulins est arrêté sur ordre
de son frère d'armes Robespierre,
et guillotiné le 5 avril 1794.
Condamné lui aussi
par le Tribunal révolutionnaire,
le député montagnard,
Georges Danton, est exécuté le même jour.
Quelques mois plus tard,
après avoir été chef du gouvernement,
c'est au tour
de l'instigateur de la Terreur,
Robespierre en personne,
de monter
sur l'échafaud le 28 juillet 1794.
Après avoir convoité
le trône de son cousin
au point de voter sa mort,
Louis-Philippe,
duc d'Orléans est condamné à son tour.
Vos bottes ?
Vous perdez votre temps,
vous me débotterez
bien plus aisément mort,
dépêchons-nous.
Il meurt le 6 novembre 1793.
Père, je ne veux plus attendre,
je veux faire pipi.
La volonté du dauphin
est un devoir pour le roi.
Nous allons nous occuper de cette envie
souveraine et pressante sans attendre.
Nous y sommes.
Allez-y doucement et visez juste,
vous nous éviterez bien des embarras.
Fini.
Voilà.
À la guerre comme à la guerre,
mon fils.
À la tête d'une France au zénith
de sa prospérité et de sa puissance,
Louis XVI aurait pu être un roi glorieux,
mais il ne fut qu'un roi martyr.
Souverain bienveillant,
instruit et intelligent,
Louis XVI aimait son peuple
avec sincérité,
mais dans le tourbillon de la Révolution,
il manqua et de clairvoyance et de chance.
Ratée, l'évasion de Louis XVI
fut le fiasco de son projet politique.
En partant
le temps d'une journée,
le roi de France avait laissé la place
à une idée nouvelle,
une idée qui allait rayonner
à travers le monde,
la République.